hello everyone thank you for tuning in
to the animal crossing new horizons
direct
today we'll be going over the details of
the update for the animal crossing new
horizons game
the update is scheduled to be released
on november 5th
[Music]
let's take a look at the free content
coming to your island
[Music]
something's coming to the museum
this is the roost a cafe owned by the
composed brewster
[Music]
kick back and relax while brewster
serves you up a cup of his finest
pan-selected coffee
[Music]
you might run into some island residents
here
[Music]
by using the animal crossing series
amiibo figures and amiibo cards in the
roost you can invite characters of your
choosing some of them may bring along
company as well
multiple players can also visit at the
same time
why not savor a relaxing cup of joe
together
[Music]
this is captain you'll find him lounging
around on your island's pier looks like
he'll ferry you to a destination via his
boat his pride and joy
it's worth the journey just to be
serenaded by his sea shanties
your destination is a hidden gem that
only captain knows about
you might docket an island with
mysterious flora
or an island with a different season
or time of day
hey it's harvest island
as you may know heart runs a photography
studio here now the island's undergoing
some changes
looks like harv wants to create a plaza
with all sorts of shops with a little
help from his longtime friend harriet
consider contributing some belts to the
cause
eventually familiar island visitors like
sahara and kix we'll set up shop here
[Music]
reason cyrus can help customize
ready-made furniture that you can't
customize on your own
[Music]
in addition katrina will reveal your
fortune for that day
fingers crossed it'll be a bustling
plaza filled with all sorts of shops
harriet might teach you some newly added
hairstyles
[Music]
try out some simple stretches by
participating in group stretching at the
plaza
you can participate too
[Music]
join in by using either button controls
or motion controls with a joy-con
controller
[Music]
stretch it out together when you invite
friends to your island or when visiting
someone else's island
[Music]
the resident representative can now
enact island ordinances
take the early bird ordinance for
example this will make all island
residents awake and active earlier in
the morning
pick the ordinance that best suits your
island lifestyle
the home services offered by tom nook
have been upgraded
more exterior options are available you
can modify your home's exterior to match
your island's landscape
also storage expansion services just got
bigger
previously home storage held up to 2 400
items
with three more expansions it now holds
up to five thousand
[Music]
newly added redeemable items will be
available for nook miles
let's see what else you can do with your
miles
cooking is coming to diy recipes
[Music]
ingredients like tomatoes
wheat
sugarcane
potatoes
carrots and more
why not make a delicious meal from your
bountiful harvest
[Music]
looks tasty
you can make all sorts of dishes to lay
across the dining table
bon appetit
[Music]
with a pro decorating license lighting
and ceiling decor can be added to each
room
[Applause]
[Music]
accent walls will also be available to
give a single wall a different pattern
with these more design options will be
at your disposal
the maximum number of bridges and
inclines you can place on your island
will increase to 10 each
[Music]
plus nine fence types including park
fencing block fencing
and corrugated iron fencing will be
added letting you diversify your island
even more
[Music]
some fencing can be customized too
[Music]
the camera app on your nook phone is
getting updated
when changing to a handheld camera mode
the view aligns with your eye level
[Music]
and if you change to a tripod camera
mode you can also be in the picture
we hope you can capture more memories
from new perspectives and angles
patterns that were previously used for
customizing items can now be worn
or used as flooring and wallpaper like
custom designs
[Music]
get in style with different hairstyles
11 hairstyles will be added
[Music]
including the ones that harriet will
teach you
[Music]
11 new reactions like waving goodbye
stretching
and bouncing to music are being added as
well get communicating even more with
these reactions
[Music]
a new nook phone app island life 101
provides tips on enjoying your island
rest assured newcomers you'll be able to
ease into island living
[Music]
additionally you'll be able to acquire
more furniture by redeeming your nook
miles
[Music]
when your pockets fill up from the day's
activities
[Music]
this storage shed will come in handy it
connects to your home storage and can be
placed almost anywhere on your island so
use it to easily store items or take
them out
and when you need some bells from your
account
this abd should also come in handy
[Music]
kk slider who holds a live concert at
the plaza every saturday will release
additional songs keep an ear out for 12
more hits like kk break
and kk polka
[Music]
you can even enjoy them from this
gorgeous sounding music box a newly
added furniture item
looks like something's buried
underground
is it a fossil
it's a gyroid
when you find gyroid fragments then
plant and water them they'll mature into
a lovely gyroid overnight
[Music]
if gyroids have grown on your island you
may find more the day after it rains
[Music]
gyroids make rather interesting sounds
experiment with different gyroid
combinations or use them with music to
bask in fresh harmonies
gyroids can be customized to match a
room's atmosphere
[Music]
nook's cranny will have newly added
furniture types available like ceiling
decor
the shop will also get furniture that's
never been seen before
[Music]
there's a new type of tool you can craft
you'll be able to permanently place
ladders on clips with the ladder setup
kit
it's super handy for getting around your
island
this diy recipe can be purchased from
nooks cranny
narrow spaces in a
[Music]
room now you can walk through them like
this
[Music]
it's a great way to navigate tight spots
and rooms with lots of furniture on
display
and let's not forget keeping up your
relationships with the other residents
you've all spent so much time together
on the island
they may invite you over to their home
[Music]
or make a surprise visit to yours
what do you think
you might experience this new content in
various ways some of them outside of
what we've shown you today
this free update version 2.0 launches
november 5th
this will be the last major free content
update for animal crossing new horizons
[Music]
we hope you'll continue enjoying your
island experience
[Music]
oh
something new is on the horizon
[Music]
our destination is this archipelago made
up of several islands
known as a resort this locale is popular
among characters searching for their
ideal vacation homes
[Music]
this is animal crossing new horizons
happy home paradise
[Music]
after a reference from tom nook you'll
assist paradise planning a resort
developer in designing vacation homes
[Music]
through your work you'll be in charge of
coordinating dream lifestyles for
characters
the goal of paradise planning is to help
characters acquire their dream vacation
homes
characters with various dreams come to
visit the office on this island
[Music]
for example meet maple
her dream vacation home is filled with
lots and lots of bears
let's make her dream a reality
first select the island on which the
vacation home will be built
each island has distinctive features
yards for instance may differ from
island to island
[Music]
pick the island that best matches the
request then head on over to the site
once you arrive on the island take a
tour of the home
place the designated furniture requested
by the client
[Music]
after that everything else is up to you
[Music]
recommended furniture from paradise
planning will already be available
pick which ones you'd like to use to
start designing
[Music]
create depth by adding lighting to the
ceiling
[Music]
spice up a wall with some wallpaper as
well
[Music]
it looks fantastic
while you're at it why not suggest ideas
for the yard
[Music]
not only can you place furniture
you can also build fences
plant trees
[Music]
and create paths
[Music]
the home's location and exterior can be
modified too
[Music]
and with the ability to modify the
season time of day and weather you can
bring a design to life that's in perfect
harmony with nature
seems like the client is pretty happy
[Music]
as you continue designing vacation homes
you'll acquire various design techniques
[Music]
for example adjusting the size of the
interior by modifying its width or
length more creative design options will
become available
[Music]
in addition you can use partition walls
to divide the space
counters with two different heights
and pillars that support the ceiling
each can help change how the home is
structured
lighting can be adjusted as well to
enhance the overall mood
[Applause]
and you can incorporate soundscapes to
add depth to the home's atmosphere
finally polishing can give a finishing
touch to the interior design
polish your furniture with care and some
effects may be added
[Music]
why not give your furniture a new
flourish
after a hard day's work head back to the
office to get compensated for your
efforts
a shop space within the office sells
rare furniture that may be hard to find
on your island
once purchased you can take it home with
you
[Music]
as you receive more requests more
furniture will become available
why not visit clients you've helped out
before
it might be good to suggest remodeling
their vacation home with different
furniture
[Music]
with your recommendation two clients can
share a vacation home
we hope they love sharing their new
piece of paradise
[Music]
say
the island on which lottie's paradise
planning office is located has a lot of
vacant buildings
you can help lottie design these as well
to make the island even more robust
take schools for example
design one by drawing inspiration from
your own memories or craft the school of
your dreams instead
other facilities such as a restaurant
can also be developed
you may be delighted seeing others using
the facilities you've designed
[Music]
the vacation homes you design are
captured in photos as design samples
then recorded in the paradise planning
portfolio
to view the portfolio use this nook
phone app happy home network
from the app you can visit the homes of
previous clients and see how they're
doing
[Music]
by connecting online you'll be able to
share your design with people from all
over the world
follow the designers you like
and view their designs to spark
inspiration for your own
[Music]
use the animal crossing series amiibo
figures and amiibo cards to invite
clients of your choosing and discuss
their ideal vacation homes
with amiibo you can design vacation
homes for these busy individuals
[Music]
the vacation homes you design for them
will hopefully make them very happy
[Music]
design techniques acquired while working
with a paradise planning team can be
used on your island
experiment with partition walls counters
pillars
[Music]
lighting
and soundscapes
you can also polish your own furniture
to spruce up your home
and by gifting your residents a special
souvenir from paradise planning they may
become interested in what the
archipelago has to offer
they may even ask you to design a
vacation home for them
[Music]
who knows someday after you've designed
a certain number of homes you might even
be able to suggest home remodels to your
island residents
[Music]
what do you think
turning every character's dream into a
reality with thorough and creative
design that's the work of paradise
planning
there's a spot open for you to join
their team and start designing
animal crossing new horizons happy home
paradise launches on november 5th as
paid additional content for animal
crossing new horizons
[Music]
pre-orders begin october 29th on
nintendo eshop
you can purchase animal crossing new
horizons happy home paradise on its own
or experience the paid additional
content as part of nintendo switch
online plus expansion pack the new
membership plan for nintendo switch
online
please visit the official website for
more details on nintendo switch online
plus expansion pack
in addition the fifth series of the
animal crossing amiibo cards will be
available
48 cards including characters previously
not on amiibo cards as well as new ones
will be released at the same time as the
update
series 5 of the animal crossing amiibo
cards will be released on november 5th
check your local retailer for details
[Music]
thanks for watching the animal crossing
new horizons direct
we hope you'll savor an even sweeter
island life and relish in the new design
experience
see you on november 5th
[Music]
you